so ganz anderes thema nordrhein
westfalens schulministerin yvonne bauer
hatte gerade eine idee
das ist meist keine gute nachricht auch
in diesem fall nicht
sie möchte nämlich dass der türkische
moschee verband ditib wieder mitreden
darf beim islamunterricht an nrw schulen
leider ist die ditib finanziert von der
staatlichen religionsbehörde in ankara
aber so was wie erdogans verlängerter
arm ist ein super signal von frau
gebauer
gerade in diesen tagen wo ganz
deutschland zu recht über antisemitismus
diskutiert der ergo ist tatsächlich
einer der besten im leistungskurs
antisemitismus neulich hat er zum
beispiel in einer rede in istanbul von
einem israelischen general erzählt dem
zitat erdo das töten von palästinensern
spaß bereitet habe um dann quasi
anekdotisch über den israeli an sich
hinzuzufügen
sibylle kinderbuch wo man kann er
mäckler anwärter
ja ich meine das geht vom bereich
legitime israel-kritik schon in den
bereich juden hast also ich bin kein
experte aber spitzen idee seine behörde
unterricht in deutschland gestalten zu
lassen wirklich da geht doch noch mehr
frau gebauer
warum nicht die afc in zukunft als
berater beim geschichtsunterricht und
deutsch natürlich von deutsch rapper
hier erklären farid bang und kollegah
foto 2 tatsächlich sind schulen gerade
jetzt gefragt aufklärung und klare kante
gegen antisemitismus gehört auf den
lehrplan
das haben die letzten wochen noch einmal
sehr schmerzhaft klar gemacht und ich
rede jetzt gar nicht direkt vom
nahostkonflikt selbst also die sind wie
die amis das nennen hochkomplexen
cluster [ __ ] israel hat natürlich ein
recht auf selbstverteidigung klar
gleichzeitig nimmt die israelische armee
bei soviel militärische überlegenheit zu
wenig rücksicht auf zivilisten die aber
wiederum von der terroristischen hamas
als schutzschilde missbraucht werden
zwei staaten lösung klingt nur noch wie
science fiction und jeder wirklich jeder
der behauptet er hätte da eine lösung
der lügt also mein vorschlag
konzentrieren wir uns doch lieber auf
das was in deutschland passiert
denn das ist deprimierend genug
aus einem protestzug heraus ertönt
plötzlich antisemitischen sprechchöre
scheiß juden skandieren die
demonstranten und das liebe kinder nennt
man antisemitismus und die
völkerrechtswidrige siedlungspolitik der
regierung netanyahu kritisieren
israel-kritik scheiß juden rufen
antisemitismus es ist gar nicht so
schwer
antisemitismus ist bei uns in
deutschland seltsamerweise immer der
antisemitismus der anderen wir haben ein
problem mit einem wohlgemerkt kleinen
teil der muslimischen community da
wegschauen wäre echt blöd haben wir zu
lange gemacht das ist aber nicht unser
einziges problem
alsbach umfrage von 2018 auf die frage
haben die juden zu viel einfluss auf der
welt antworten 55 prozent der befragten
afd anhänger mit ja bei den anderen
parteien sind es zwischen 16 und 20
prozent von dem was man auf querdenker
dem musik mal ganz zu schweigen
hier treffen gehen kann zeigen und gehen
haben sich der dieb steht und hier heißt
so schnell wohl hier
rockefeller und konsorten rothschild die
emsstadt aussieht doch der ein virus das
thema dieser dieser dieser die sache
hier platt machen können die europa und
deutschland und die verstrahlung der
menschheit rochat und diese kreise die
juden wollen schon wieder deutschland
fast larven die etwas andere
interpretation der weltgeschichte
hoffentlich ist der mann in behandlung
seit 2015 ist die zahl der
antisemitischen straftaten hier um mehr
als zwei drittel gestiegen was mit
bürger jüdischen glaubens erleben wenn
sie zum beispiel mit kippa durch
bestimmte stadtteile laufen das ist eine
schande für uns alle wirklich oder dass
jede jüdische einrichtung von der
polizei bewacht werden muss überhaupt
erstaunlich wie oft leute die angeblich
nur israel kritisieren wollen synagogen
angreifen wie 2017 beim brandanschlag in
wuppertal
danach gab es ja dieses skandalurteil
vom oberlandesgericht düsseldorf das
dann entschieden hat dass dieser angriff
auf die sinne
google eben kein antisemitisches hass
verbrechen sondern zitat zu weit
gegangen in israel kritik gewesen seid
auch guck mal an ein brandanschlag ist
also konstruktive kritik wieder was
gelernt
dafür muss man wohl jura studiert haben
nicht nur der rechtsstaat wir als
gesellschaft müssen konsequent dagegen
halten und zwar in allen milieus das
betrifft zugewanderte aus muslimischen
ländern in denen antisemitismus quasi
staatsraison ist aber eben auch den
rentner von nebenan in unserem review
die sagen ja das sind die bereiche leute
und die wollen uns unterdrücken und
wirklich was also alles unsinn unsere
ganz genau die frau hat völlig recht
man will gar nicht wissen was in manchen
doppelkopf runden so abgeht nach dem
dritten eierlikör und hier das ist auch
großer teil des problems telegramm das
heads medium vom dienst in diktaturen
durchaus hilfreich weil ja jeder alles
posten darf aber auch ganz schlimm weil
ja jeder alles posten darf auf telegramm
kannst du in einer gruppe mit bis zu
200.000 leuten den holocaust leugnen und
ihr passiert original nichts da ist
wirklich ein rechtsfreier raum
entstanden während facebook und co
hassbotschaften unter androhung von
bußgeldern löschen müssen muss telegram
als messenger dienst gar nichts was
genau macht das mit den usern
wir haben uns dazu mal ein innovatives
menschenexperiment getraut
[Musik]
alexander wipprecht ein ganz normaler
links-grün sozialisierter comedy
redakteur
er soll sich einen ganzen tag lang nur
über den telegramm kanal von attila
hildmann informieren
wir wollen wissen was macht das mit
[Musik]
das hat mich alles nicht gewusst
da sieht man hier zum beispiel das ist
dann habe und da sind alle institute die
bei dieser corona plan der nie
mitgemacht haben die gehören zu der
leopoldina also zu den freimaurern von
den leopoldina ja klar natürlich frei
machen
freiburg das fängt ja auch beides mit
frei an heute ist freitag
es kann auch alles kein zufall sein
er bricht ist gut ausgebildete
akademiker sein gehirn wehrt sich mit
aller kraft gegen mons kanal erfolg die
tür zum wahnsinn ist aufgeschlossen
zitat hitler war ein segen für
deutschland im vergleich zu merkel
dieser kommunistin ich distanziere mich
deutlich von neonazis und nazis beide
sind erfindungen fusion um das dritte
reich zu diskreditieren eben hier wird
der gute ruf des reiches mutwillig
zerstört können wir mit dem kanal jetzt
wieder aufhören bitte
[Musik]
rupprecht tritt endgültig durch wie sein
idol hildmann wird er schließlich auch
noch veganer
wir müssen das experiment abbrechen und
den feuern anzugucken alexander
wipprecht was für ein opfer
[Musik]
so aufnahme
hallo dies ist die automatische and cut
von oliver welke und der heute show
leider ist das video schon vorbei ihr
könnt den kanal allerdings gerne
abonnieren und ein weiteres video
anschauen vielen dank so müsse jetzt für
immer reicher